[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
the foreseeable future
i did see a piece of communication
saying we may be a few months i'm hoping
not something that we will continue to
keep monitoring
and um
as soon as it's practical we would look
at going back into
a meeting in person so just so that you
know
all know that so um
uh firstly apologies have i got new
apologies today
because it's on the screen
no apologies um no conflicts of interest
yeah yes mr miller i'm 8.5 i may have a
conflict because i at least land on
under that system although it's probably
a non-event because i'm going to vote
for it anyway but um perhaps we should
record it probably be wise and you'll
consider your position on that
and just
for your benefit
under reactions if you want to speak
please use the raised hand function
because it just pushes everyone to the
top and if you'd like to move or second
something there is if you could use your
thumbs up
um so nikki did you have a question um
no i think i've got a conflict on 17.7
okay nicki
is mike neville as well
sorry
okay right we'll deal with that when we
come to those just remind me in case i
overlook that by excellent
all right so um firstly we've got
acknowledgements
um
we have a a
and then by way of an obituary so the
first is for bruce mckeig
formerly an air
county councillor from 1974 to 1989
including the 1987 to 89 period when the
year county council orangura district
council
i mean jointly every month so that's the
first and the second um he's not a
resident of the district but deeply
mayor atkinson made me reminded me this
morning
of colin the modio
who's an historian he's written a number
of books
in and around kaiapoi one around kaibo
with blackwell's
uh the two hoy and the kaiapoi port and
there may well be others
other ones i could locate so
i'm not going to ask you to all stand
but if we could just observe a moment's
silence
thank you
all right now we now come to the
confirmation of minutes
uh 4.1 is the first it's the council
meeting on the 1st of february i
understand
deep americans you have a correction to
be recorded there
you can unmute
thank you mr mayor you're just on
page 19
table 10
on 4.1
um
it says there
um and i'll try and bring it up
um
it says there that i voted against and
then the division said that i
voted for
i clearly voted against
yes that's i recall you doing so so um
in a minute we'll is there any other
corrections counselor barnett are you
indicating
yes on page six of the minutes
it said that i'd stated there were no
other 30 kilometer per hour areas in the
district whereas i'd actually said no
other 30 kilometers per hours except at
the beach settlements
okay
i'm happy to accept your word on there
so with that this is any other
corrections
deputy mayor atkinson
and councillor barnard are you happy to
move
the reception these minutes is with
those corrections
any discussion
i'll put that all those in favor
please say i just indicate with your
hand
anyone
opposed to clear those
minutes except
or confirmed
now the next is item 4.2
which is the minutes for confirmation
of the 2nd of february which was our
annual plan
um
deliberations
council redmond
you've got two thumbs up
sorry mr mayor i'm trying to delete them
so you don't have anything uh counts of
duty
you just need to unmute windy i can't
hear you sorry
you're okay
all right
so someone prepared to move seems you've
got multiple hands in the ear council
redmond you're moving
secreted by
council award
um any discussion
i'll put those all those in favor please
say aye
contrary to clear that carried any
measures arising
okay
we um the amount of the public excluded
minutes will deal with that when we go
into the px agenda
i have no disputations or presentations
for today just noting adjourned business
uh there which is to do with development
contributions that will be dealt with on
the public excluded agenda
i'm just checking can you all hear me
okay
good
um so now we come to um number seven
which is the
uh shuffle ready project 7.1 so
that's here are you going to let uh
colin
into the meeting is that correct
um yes sorry mr chairperson are you
skipping um adjourning business item six
well it's dealt with the public excluded
so sorry yes okay no trouble but thank
you for checking giving me all my toys
which is excellent
so we
it's colin roxbury now and rob kerr
yeah they are coming in now
thank you
so it's pages 72-79
everyone
is tab five uh diligent
so um
colin and rob will leave this in your
hands who's who wishes to speak
uh hi everyone oh i'll speak and colin
will um we'll fill in um i've only just
joined the meeting so i'm hoping i'm
joining at the right time to uh to speak
to the stimulus program uh paper
excellent
so
this paper is uh what
should be the final
paper that you see in relation to the
stimulus program at work of course
you'll recall that this
is based on the uh
the
8.02 million dollar grant from the crown
relation to the three waters reform
process plus additional funding that you
committed
from both level of service and
development contributions towards a
program of work that covers i think it's
ten construction
uh
jobs plus another four or five um
operational and non-construction works
so total budget is 10.605 to date
but our recommendation is to consider
that
as we've completed all tendering
and
we were
aiming it up
pretty nicely to meet all budgets but
the last 10 to the low burnley ashley
wastewater main which is the last stage
of the low burn lee scheme
came in over the engineers estimate with
only a single
single bid
it's about 150k over budget
and that's
how much over budget the the overall
program is
so with
the unders and overs and um of the
different uh different projects both
um overall but more particularly by
funding source as well um
everything's able to be covered except
for that hundred and fifty uh thousand
000
now you may recall and colin will be
able to explain this better than i can
that uh when you
approve the overall program there was a
mechanism put in place for some
um
the benefiting schemes to provide a
return to the to the schemes they were
joining um into the overall
rating base so that was originally set
at 560 000
um
it was uh it gives some room to
uh maneuver for the inherent uncertainty
in the overall program cost and so our
recommendation was for you to consider
that that
uh
that redistribution has reduced to 409
000 and the 151 thousand dollars is
has moved to the um
to the low band lee budget
to be able to deliver that last section
of work
you have other options of course your
options is not to do that work um or to
um consider other budgets that you may
wish to um
uh
move around however from a staff
perspective we'd recommend that this is
the um
the best approach uh because it's work
that needs to be done
um
that is my story um and have you
answered any questions or and kyle i may
wish to um fill in some additional
information as well
thanks colin do you want to add anything
no i think rob's done a great job so
i'll just um help respond to questions
if needed
thank you counselor thank you could you
please mute yourself
um no because the last time i did i
couldn't come out of it again okay all
right i'm scared to try okay fair enough
um
question so if you would like questions
or want to speak please use the
reactions the raise hand function
is there any questions
um
yes i can see you raising your hand
there counselor
um
council ward be followed by
council support could you use the under
reactions use ray's hand which is at the
bottom it just pulls you to the top then
i know you're there
thank you but i'm noting that you're
asking a question
yeah the question the question is that
um
with these tenders going out and the
work that has to be done we're going to
are we going to get these all done in
the timely fashion so that we can
maximize um the funding
so
the answer is yes all all works subject
to your decision today are on
uh on schedule to be completed by the
due date and the funding agreement which
actually changed across the country
until june uh 2000 that june this year
uh but we're well in advance of that and
in fact we're well in advance of we've
almost spent
um eight million dollars already if we
haven't already we may have this month i
haven't done the figures yet so
um
so we we we're not at risk in my view of
um
of breaching the funding agreement
thank you will um yeah i'll vote for the
recommendation thank you
thank you
uh councillor williams
yeah hi um the logan lee um the growth
scenario an extra 1.47
million
um
there was nowhere near that originally
have we actually got that growth um
happening or is that just um
where is that 1.4 mill come from
uh colin do you want to um respond to
that please
yeah so i'm looking at the table under
recommendation b
we're not proposing any changes to that
growth budget it's so the the august 20
21 budget which was the last time we
looked at these was 1.47 the proposed
budget
is still 1.47 so
that hasn't changed since august um
so you'll be not looking to make up any
difference by changing the gross budget
so we we had um
part of our consideration with that as
making sure
that well partly the growth has to
reflect the growth um funding has
reflect the benefit of the projects
um split between growth and the existing
rate payers but also it has to be at a
level
where the resultant development
contributions are
affordable that they're not going to
prohibit growth happening so
i think yeah that's that was our view
back then and it still was that that's
about the right
amount of growth funding and the
development contributions are also in
line with other schemes um
and we have had
interest from developers about growth in
that area so within the lifetime
of this um
yeah we definitely expect to recover
that over the coming um years
thanks so much
so you have hear the question council
williams
well yeah i just wanted to know how many
years um we expected before we try to
start recovering some of this money
is it uh
one year two year or ten years
uh it's it's within it could be up to
ten years um to recover so it's not
necessarily immediate but it's that's um
that's very common for projects like
this to have a growth element to them
some of it could be so you know we had
one developer last year who was um
really keen to get things underway as
soon as possible i haven't heard of that
progress since but there's definitely in
general a lot of interest from
developers to wherever land is owned for
growth to go ahead and do it but we we
always try to be a little bit
conservative and allow a longer time
period
thank you
um
i see council meetings but just just to
remind everyone
can you please use the raised hand
function so it's a
slight bit that's on the reactions
because
when you use yours nikki it just looks
like you're waving you're clapping in
support uh actually it's the raised hand
function that pushes you to the top and
i know that you want to ask a question
but that's all right just like counselor
atkinson is well done there we go thank
you councilmanix
[Music]
maybe i should have my glasses on zebras
i'm sorry about that guys i was like why
did that keep disappearing but um there
you go everybody can make a faux pas on
zoom they're all getting used to this
[Laughter]
um
yeah but what i wanted to ask was has
this project increased by 416 000 over
the extended budget
for which the
255k was added
back in august or is it 416 over the
original budget
does that makes sense
um for low very slowly
yeah
that makes sense i think it'll be fair
to say that we have had a number of
challenges on this uh construction
project it's a very long pipeline and
certainly the estimates probably won't
went up to where we uh we would hope to
in terms of levels of accuracy from the
initial first cuts so
um
the
416 is an addition to the
um
the increase at the last in the august
meeting
so part of that part of those increases
is caused by increased
increased scope the amount of work that
needed to be done particularly around
services and some of the ground
conditions but it also i think it
reflects that the market conditions that
we're seeing at the moment
uh certainly
there are
to have received a
one tender for a relatively
normal job like this uh a pipeline job
like this is unusual
enough thank you okay further questions
we have a series of recommendations that
some are appeared to me
i'll put your hands up at once counselor
brian
will move seconded by council reckinson
council brian
uh well we heard a pretty clear staff
report and good questions good answers
nothing for you to add
thank you councillor atkinson do you
wish to speak
any further speakers
you can exercise a right to reply to
yourself if you like council brian
i'll put the recommendation
all those in favor please say hi
raise your hands
contrary
clear that carrie so
thanks rob and colin
the easters um
oh there's another writing that will
follow in the px which is listed there
which is
we'll deal with the public excluded the
next is
8.1 which is land acquisition so that's
uh tab
uh six pages 80 to 127.
so we've got chris
speaking to this report hi chris killed
everyone um so this report uh refers to
land acquisition of 200 and a parcel of
property which is deeds land next to 260
rebels road in kaiapoi
um
this piece of land forms part of the
arahatia first
project which looks to create a loop
around what we sometimes call the
horseshoe
on the cam river the eventual plan looks
to link
kaiapoi
and rangiora
with a recreational
track that they can use
following the cam river to get from
kaipurangura and vice versa along with
some planting
riparian planting
and biodiversity enhancement we've
already started the project there's been
significant amounts of consultation with
nearby residents who we are
getting quite a bit of support from now
we've planted
many thousands of plants along another
part of the cam river which forms part
of this walkway originally when we
looked at the piece of land in question
um we were working with um the landowner
at the time that of 260 rebels road and
we had it surveyed and found that
there was quite a large portion um which
was in this deeds land ownership as
opposed to the person at 260 revels road
they weren't managing their fences
particularly well they were stopped
getting in the river et cetera et
the surveyor um
as you'll see from the report did a very
thorough job on getting all of the
historical records and they determined
that it was uh road reserve
um we subsequently after sending the
plans to linz we're told that while the
intention in 1870 something by the
owner at the time was for it to be
given to the council as road reserve
there's no evidence to suggest that the
council at the time or the authority at
the time ever actually accepted it so
therefore it remains as deeds land
um
we
have been working with sheehan at
coconut and french to try and massage
linz into taking a pragmatic view on
the ownership
or status of the land he's been unable
to do that
so our next step is to compulsively
acquire the land using the um public
works act and i've put in the report a
process of how that would um how we
would go about doing that so i'm looking
for
council
support
in order to go through that process
which is required as part of that
process happy to take any questions
thank you
questions thanks chris questions
council blackie
yeah hi chris um having been involved
with one of these as you know and you
were back in the day at um silverstream
reserve here two questions
where are we up to with discussing what
you intend to do with the current
owners at 260 and and i understand they
it changed hands didn't it quite
recently do the do the current tenants
it wouldn't start again when when the
current tenants bought it were they made
aware that this project what was in the
pipeline
yeah so we've gone out and met with the
current landowner um and i've only owned
the piece of land for three or four
months now um they
have been
previously we'd actually got to the
stage of actually having a license to
occupy um for the previous owner based
on the fact that part of their garage is
actually on the land which is now
considered deeds land so we gave them
that license component said if we go
through this compulsory acquisition
process then we'll have to give you a
licensed occupy for part of your garage
as well
we had a good walk over the site and
they were fully supportive they actually
come from an environmental background
hold a position
in a
an authority nearby where
they are looking after biodiversity um
and
waterways etc so
um they
told us that they'd killed 19 possums on
the piece of land since they'd been
there and were fully supportive and
wanted to do a whole bunch of stuff to
actually support the project um going
ahead so they were very supportive
haven't haven't contacted the um agents
of the um previous owner of the deeds
land um because
that might be really hard seeing as no
one's been interested in it since 1874.
thank you um through the further
questions
uh council prime
so i was just a little confused with
this
report sorry chris i didn't ring you
yesterday um
there's no other option
than the process that you're proposing
then yeah
um so there are other options um one of
the options would be to look to bridge
the cam river to make sure that the
recreational walkway can get to the
other side of course the cost of doing
that
is huge um
it also means that we'll have a piece of
land which is sitting next to the cam
which remains deeds land that we don't
have any power to actually plant plants
protect make sure that the banks aren't
eroding into the river et cetera
so regardless of whether we actually
create a walkway we'd still like to have
control over the piece of land to make
sure that the primary objectives of
arohatiya which are water quality and
biodiversity enhancement
are achieved as well the other option
would be to just start somewhere else
with the arohatiyatiyawa project
start on the other side of the river all
the way from kaiapoi we do have issues
there with the likes of the mill um and
other land ownership
issues where there isn't actually a
piece of um deeds land at all and people
own right up to the edge of the river
which means that we can't get there
can't plant plants etc so we've looked
at all the options and we believe that
this is the best one to be able to
continue with arohatiyatio
i i guess where i was coming from was
more in the money sense this has cost us
and will cost us
does money come into the equation can
yep i know the ownership's in dispute
but
can can not the ownership be bought
well that's deeds land so there's no one
essentially to buy it off so
the process is identified in the in the
report but they have to go through first
of all and try and find out who the
agent is for the land and that might
mean going back to 1870 and then
following a reasonably wiggly line
through to someone that might exist
today
and that takes a little bit of research
and time the positive the process which
has been identified in the report you
will note that it says partially
complete on a number of those because we
have done a very detailed investigation
with the surveyor um so we don't need to
do any of that work again so so that
will reduce the cost but
yeah there's always a process around
deeds then
if we could find the owner ourselves
which is unlikely and then look to buy
it off them it might be cheaper but um i
don't think that's going to be likely
further questions
so we have a
thank you to move
so it counts
so hold on so
so i've got cut thank you i know you're
moving council students over at council
redmond
council meetings oh you'll have your
second right
do you have a question then council
records right so council readman first
followed by councillor atkinson
uh no i was going to move or second but
i've been uh beaten to the punch
okay um council atkinson hi
okay so
council stuart's moved seconded by
council meetings stuart do you wish to
speak
yes thank you just briefly um
uh
mr brown's report outlines the
issue um uh at um in front of us um and
includes as you'll see those fascinating
old maps um
so there's been quite a lot of research
going back to get us to this point i
find it
quite extraordinary that
a reserved road which guaranteed public
access in the subdivision survey
back in 1860 is not actually recognized
by linz at this point
in order to be able to
carry out that purpose
because there's no evidence that it
transferred over to a
a local authority at the time and you
have to ask the question well i
certainly did was um
who else was going to
fulfill this purpose and maintain it
to
to enable public access
through the area
so that's why we're at where we're at
and the public
works act gives the council the ability
to
see the strip of land and it's
10 meters from the river edge
along the
um accompanying the boundary or
beside the adjoining the boundary of
260. so it's a
a sliver of land
um so this the public works that enables
um
uh the council to fulfill the original
um purpose plus
um complete the first section of of
track coming from kaiboy up to the
rebels road
um
bridge and
deliver the benefits of
to the river and the riverbank
environment as as mr brown said
there's stock uh getting into the river
along the stretch
um and um a fence along the boundary of
1860
will enable
that to
not occur again and us to enhance the
riverbank environment with them
with native plantings so um and enable
everybody to enjoy it
so um i encourage everybody to support
the recommendation thank you
thanks council stuart council meetings
do you wish to speak
yes please uh yes well being being
privileged to sit on the other hatia
committee alongside councillor stewardes
too um it's been a really interesting
process to see this all unravel um it
was
quite a shock i suppose to find out that
this this land in question was deep land
in the first place and we had hoped for
an easier path to get
the land into
a proper state that we could do
what what needs to be done with it but
this is this is a
very important project it's already
under
you know well underway we've got
residents that are
honestly um
have been really good to work with we
couldn't ask for better people living in
the land in question at the moment um
and the fact that lynn's
will not be massaged as chris put it
into making this a little bit of an
easier path is disappointing but
considering that this is our only way
forward
i do hope that you all will all consider
the recommendation because
otherwise it puts what is an excellent
project at risk and
i think we'd all hate to see that
so i hope you'll support it thanks
counselor dude did i see you put your
hand up here
council dating followed by councillor
brian
you might wanna knew wendy
this was extremely interesting to read
and i'm so fascinated by the deeds
the writing the way they've done it it's
just incredible with the beautiful
handwriting
um and variant one i could read it was
very interesting to read through the
that part of history that can and being
in 18
march 1889
so how interesting
thank you
body supporter
thank you councillor brian
thank you mr mayor my my question
is prefaced on it
only in about five at least in five
occasions have we ever had to use this
process to to acquire land um and and i
find it unfortunate um
that we're having to go this way this
makes perfect complete and absolute
common sense and it's just done it
johnny unfortunate that it's uh we've
had to go this way
thank you well i'm i'm also going to
support uh this i agree with council
briana rather we're having to go by a
public works heck but
having been involved in some other areas
that involve deeds and it's it's a very
difficult exercise so really
we really don't have any other choice uh
claudistic i'd really like to
acknowledge and thank councilman stewart
for her leadership in this area i think
she's doing a superb job and i've i've
and i fully support
this because i
i think the work's been done and the
report
itself chris um very thorough
and explained it really well so thank
you for the work it's an area that i
think we can be very proud of our
achievements here and again thank
councillor stewart and others who are
involved in supporting this project
council redmond
thank you mr mayor um this is something
that's fascinating to retired lawyers
and historians um it's a very
comprehensive report and the deed system
is a can of worms
there are other ways of treating
it but they're not simple
uh they're convoluted and time-consuming
so this really is um
one way to hit it on the head and uh
resolve the issue and i think it will be
cost effective too compared with the
other alternatives
and there are little patches of land
like this throughout the district and
i i personally find it quite fascinating
thank you council redmond any further
speakers
surprise reply counselor stuart good
luck
no all good
i think you are going to put the
recommendation
all those in favor please say aye
contrary
to that kerry
thank you all right we've now come to
8.2 which is the um thanks chris the
housing working group interim report
mr markham that's pages one two eight
two five three
tab seven
thanks simon
um good afternoon councillors uh so this
is as uh
highlighted an interim report
um covers many
aspects of the housing topic
try to layer the information
from the main report to a number of
attachments
and really
does tries to do two things give you
as the whole council a sense of the
progress and directions of inquiry of
the group and secondly
the
matters that will come before you
such as the greater christchurch housing
strategy and uh recommends that
those relevant to the housing topic be
brought
to the working group to provide you and
turn with advice in an integrated way on
those matters so
with that introduction i'm pleased to
answer any questions and it may be that
um councillor atkinson is chair of a
group or other members of the working
group may wish to
make some introductory remarks as well
thank you
thanks uh simon counselor atkinson would
you like to make any introductory
remarks
you can now mute yourself
if you want to
any mr mayor of
troubles here with a mouse that seems to
be crawling all over the place i don't
know whether it's been rat poisoned or
not but
um
look this is
just to let everybody know that this
group we've worked worked pretty hard to
get to the stage and as you can see by
the reporters
it's quite encompassing of a whole
raft of things and
uh we are really at a reasonably interim
stage of um of getting through it um
we've we've worked with uh with some
people in gaining information um and we
intend to work with a lot more and gain
information as we go along before we get
to the next report which hopefully won't
be too far away simon might give some
indication of when he thinks that um
may be assembled in the in
you know months to come but um
we are we are getting there there is a
lot of an awful lot of demand in the
space and it is
has very very many
tentacles that go out everywhere into
the community
and then again as soon as um indicated
we'll feed into the gps
as well as uh what we need to do in our
own community um we have some focuses as
you can see that in the report there um
in the interim report that we are um
focusing on um and i think they will
narrow uh
by the next report reasonably quickly
and um
and will actually have even a better
indication for you in the next few
months but simon you you may give you
may have a view on them about how long
you think that we will be
thank you councillor look i think there
are a number of um
uh
smaller work streams within this topic
area that will progress quite quickly as
councillor atkinson has indicated i
think that working group is keen to be
able to make some recommendations to you
sooner rather than later as to
the best way of
allocating the funds reserved in the
housing space that the council does have
remembering those are out of sale
proceeds of
former community housing and i think
that's a priority to get
a an appropriate
um
uh delivery
option before the council as soon as
practical in that space
others will take a little bit longer
the staff are
subject to your deliberations on this
report staff will be working up an
implementation
program for the various actions that are
foreshadowed in it
and that will come back as a matter
apart from discussion by the housing
working group at its next meeting coming
up soon in march it would
could be circulated to full council to
give you an indication of time frames
thank you very much thanks simon um
councilman followed by council brian and
the council of duty
thank you simon thank you mr mayor um
simon i'm just wanting to tease out the
budget issue that's been put in here of
the 35 000 being brought forward
why wasn't that raised at the annual
planned deliberations and has been
brought to march council
so i i i think
the the
full breadth of the
program implement implications of the
housing working groups into a report
just wasn't available at that time as we
went into the budget
and and it has
um in discussion with the housing
working group there's a desire to make
progress
um
and we do have a significant resource
implication a resourcing implication in
the property uh unit uh which is
limiting that in the short terms hence
that
rather than waiting until the first of
july to begin recruitment
for that new position
there's a preference expressed to
advance that sooner rather than later
so supplementary to that oh sorry
i was just going to say that that
actually came about counselor data
through
a suggestion of the
of the panel to recommend this because
there is just there is some ambition
around this program but there is
staffing measures there we could discuss
that very briefly with this be
this to come as a way of um
so there's a noise coming in there from
somewhere um around the
uh that amount be brought to this
panel or near ordinarily yes we would
wait until july but given the ambitions
it was felt that it would be appropriate
to bring here and that could be just
deficit funded until july because there
were a number of positions proposed
through
two positions proposed through the
annual plan
and any events it was just bringing that
partially forward
today to the site thank you for
answering
um just then supplementary to that
my original understanding of the housing
working group was it was formed to
distribute the funds that we had
available from the sale of property and
also to look at our long-term strategy
for our elderly housing and the rental
units we had
why has the scope suddenly been
broadened so much reading through the
documentation
to become part of the greater
christchurch
housing strategy when christchurch city
council has a completely different
portfolio
and involvement in housing than
waimakariri district council
i could offer a couple of comments in
that regard firstly
the
terms of reference of the housing
working group which are attachment one
have five work streams five objectives
and we've reported
and the working group has reported
against all five of those
um and that is inclusive of the matters
that you raise counsellor but it was
on its uh formation in may last year
had a rather wider brief than i think
you are referring to
and secondly the greater christchurch
housing social affordable housing work
stream
is a matter that is going to come to the
council regardless of whether
there is a housing working group or not
that was initiated through the greater
christchurch partnership i think the the
recommendation before you is that
um and you're going to get a briefing on
that i think
uh on this coming thursday
about a full document in due course that
the appropriate course of action uh
recommended is to refer that to the
working group so that it can
be cognizant of what is being
proposed at a greater christchurch level
and provide this council with advice in
terms of what might be an appropriate
response to that from a district
perspective
so final question mr mayor given that
central government since 2011 has been
pushing local government out of uh
social housing area inc including um the
income related rent subsidy being
removed from local government and
kayunga ora's role being stepped up
why are we now being asked to provide
such actual resources towards funding
a role to do with housing which is
clearly comes under the central
government uh taxation portfolios
a couple of comments uh in relation to
your remarks firstly um
local government have never enjoyed the
income related rent scheme uh that was
um created um principally to support
the development of the community housing
sector
uh
that is um and it's not a criticism but
it's an observation
there is very little community housing
in the waimakariri district
but you are right the government in the
general sense over a very long period of
time and its
successive governments from the early
1990s
have been rather parsimonious about
local government's role in housing and
as a consequence
this council along with many others are
the
steward custodian of a number of elderly
persons housing units
um
a portfolio of 112 in the case of
waimakariri but most of the there's
about 50 councils in new zealand with
between 100 and 300 eph units the
question is
and it's
addressed in some of the work that's
included in the in this report by way of
attachment looking out longer term
in terms of the pattern of household
demand for housing by age and household
size
there's a a a clear strategic
direction of demonstrable needs in the
older smaller household sector that is
unlikely to be provided by the market
now fortunately
kangaora has um
has moved from what was a a principal
focus when it was a housing corporation
on three-bedroom family housing and is a
provider in that space the question uh
that that is before us though is with
very rapidly rising waiting lists there
is a general shortage of social housing
full stop
thank you councillor brian
thank you um i'm assured it was
coincidental but last week i received a
email from velda rivoli
and i
posed some questions to rob and thank
you very much rob for getting back to me
and i hadn't read this report that time
my question is what do you expect those
reserves to ultimately be that we can
invest
in social housing
i've got a comment on that but it may
well be that members of the housing
working group would also want to reply
carry on
i think there's a desire to see them
reinvested principally in the elderly
person's
area
they're aware of the abbey fields option
that
um which there is now a local
group uh well organized and i believe
they will be coming to present to the
housing working group at its next
meeting
the question of the particular form of
housing that abbey fields
is
promoting is is one option in the
elderly person space
and and i'm sure that we'll get a good
consideration at the next housing
working group meeting
thank you
thank you rob did you want to add
anything there well no i was just cur
i just checked if robbie can i just
check if rob wanted to add anything
today rob waltham wrong did you want it
to answer uh
only that i think the question was what
sort of quantum
of dollars uh
uh if that was the question um
and um it's a approximately 2.5 million
now that's the equity
there is potential in a sustainable way
um to
have
somewhat greater spend than that
in terms of being able to borrow against
the asset
but in terms of the cash that came out
of the sale of those properties about
2.5 million
thank you
um
no further questions that i could see
um but did you have a question account
sorry i saw you put your hand up there
were a wave there before we did uh
council duty did you have a question
no it wasn't a question i was just going
to make a comment when um they asked
what the other rest of the housing
housing unit would do what i'll do is we
will come to debate
but if you want to add anything out
there
and members of the other house
housing weekend group you're welcome to
now otherwise if we could save it to
debate we can have it there but i'm
happy to
encourage to to let you speak if you
wish
thank you um yes
[Music]
it's been a very interesting
time looking at all these this the
center with working with the housing
working group
um
sadly with because of coba a lot of us
some of us didn't get to see the um
one or two uh projects that would have
been could have been interesting to
thirty and one of them of course wasn't
um um
the project that that uh um robbie just
spoke about a few moments ago
unfortunately see that but also there
was one in
peterborough street i would have liked
to have been able to have a little look
at but unfortunately covered um does
tend to interrupt things a bit so
hopefully we'll be able to
one day go and have thanks
thank you
uh robbie did you have another question
or you just still got your hand up no
okay uh council atkinson did you wish to
i would just be happy to move mr mayor
okay so any further questions it's a
move by councillor atkinson i think that
means you're wanting the second council
duty yes
okay um
that's moved and seconded would you like
to speak council recklessly
thank you mr mayor look this is um this
has been an interesting um uh committee
that we've been uh that we've we've been
all been on and
grappled with at times um what's the
involvement where is it going
what sort of money have we got to invest
uh expectations from the community which
are very high and think we will invest
in all manners of
of social housing and you can probably
imagine um
just about everybody wants us to invest
in in their project and of course as it
should be every area um
in housing
is something um that people are
incredibly passionate about
um and uh councilvana uh raises the the
uh effect of uh whether we should be
involved how we should be involved
that's exactly what we are looking at
and exactly under the delegations what
what it is
that we need to be doing it may come out
at the end of the day that apart from
the investment money that we have that
there may be something completely
different that's needed at the end of
this um and i'm not sure that there is
ever an end in housing i think it's um
always the start of the big uh sorry the
end of the beginning um no matter where
you're ahead of it
abby fields yes they did come and see us
uh when he's right about uh peterborough
street we've got kaianga aura we've had
a company called modis who have come and
seen us uh we have several more in which
we um
we wish to hear from
in tess's space i think there's about uh
i suppose a nod simon about 14 different
groups in which
she's dealing with in the social housing
and it goes from intellectually
handicapped right through again to
kaianga aura mentioned again
so
it's a pretty complex area and it's
it's getting worse as the days goes on
as far as complexity goes because the
rise and questionably the fall in um
in rentals
typology that people need to live in all
of those things it changes
day by day
um so we need to keep up with that
we started from well behind
we had
our pension pensioner units and we had
the seven homes in which we um uh sold
and obviously where the money um has co
accumulated from
so
we haven't looked at that apart from
when rob and i were involved in the
original group that bought those
those seven homes originally
um apart from that
and what we've rob
hawthorne has done recently with the
pension pensioner housing we haven't
looked at this for a very very long time
and we're playing catch up
so what i am asking is that you support
this interim report
and
and help us through to continue to
gather information and inform you what
it is that we will need to do hopefully
in the very near future with the money
that we have but also in assisting the
community
whether it should be government whether
it should be us and some advice coming
back to you um that we can all put our
stamp on to to move forward in the space
thanks councillor atkinson i have uh
councillors duty redmond and barnett and
as i said before if you could please use
the reactions this counts the bar of
hairs then i i saw the order but you're
raising things but raising your hand
helps me to know who's there
so if you do that please
um so council duty as second
thank you
yes um councillor atkinson's quite
correct what he was saying that we've
been grappling with this
and
as a portfolio holder of pensioner
housing i was a bit appalled at the
conditions of some of those pensioner
housing and i will say thank you to rob
and his team for
getting in and making sure some of those
pension housings are up to scratch now
and uh to keep a healthy home
um more than more so
and we we are really falling behind uh
and we do need to step up
but just as to how how how much we do
step up and and who we we look after
that is something for
council to actually grapple with in the
long
term when we put our final
recommendations together but it is a
very interesting working party to be on
and so thank you
thank you
council dirty councillor redmond
thank you mr mayor um
i'm also a member of the committee
and it has been a very interesting
process
and i'd like to um congratulate simon
and the staff for the report the area
just grew from what i first anticipated
it may have been
and uh
it is a very broad area
i'm hopeful as i think councillor
atkinson indicated that we may focus on
some specific areas
in the not too distant future
but i think this is a very good interim
report a very comprehensive set of
recommendations and i'm happy to support
them thank you
thanks council redmond councillor
just one question first mr mayor is it
possible to take section m which is the
budgetary item separately yes i'm happy
with that
thank you
um just speaking to this housing is an
absolute critical item in new zealand at
the moment and we see it every day on
the news
i have utmost um sympathy for people who
are struggling to find housing and i do
feel the government has failed to look
at the aging demographic of our
community but we have to look quite
clearly at what our role is under
legislation and it's not clear that we
are supposed to be spending ratepayers
money in this space traditionally
council's role has always been a
regulatory function we have the resource
management act the building act the
health act
and we are supposed to try and encourage
infrastructure and incentivize
development by private providers
providing private capital to build the
appropriate housing in our district uh
we're also there and i totally support
facilitating other social providers to
provide housing models in our district
very much like the rest of our community
team activities where we facilitate
social services but we don't run them
and we certainly don't fund them i was
really really quite surprised to see a
budgetary item come to us in march when
we just considered the annual plan back
in january and that hadn't been
indicated that any budgetary item would
go in regarding housing when we haven't
actually consulted with our community as
to how much of their rates they would
like to spend on housing in our district
one of the reasons why makarere hasn't
been very involved in social housing is
we have a very high rate of home
ownership i think it's around 86 simon
somewhere around there so we haven't had
the demonstratable need that
christchurch city council and other
councils have
of very high levels of need in social
housing
we also don't have the staff who can
accommodate looking after people who
have need other wraparound services and
social housing and the government has
taken away our mechanisms to fund it
easily and has pushed that back to the
community sector so i very much saw this
role as looking at the money we had that
was dedicated in the budget or to
already existing houses and there seemed
to be a general consensus around council
that the the need was going to be an
elderly person's housing
facilitating all the other agencies in
our district who are working to provide
housing for our residents and and being
that go between with information
supporting infrastructure and so on i've
never agreed to us spending other money
on extra staff to facilitate social or
affordable housing in the industry i
believe that sits in the community team
and in partly in the housing team who
looks after our pensioner house units so
i will be voting against the budget uh
provision simply because i think the 17a
review where we consult with our
community about what they want in terms
of our housing policy should have been
done first we need to know what the
public want us to spend in housing
before we add anything extra to the
budget and pull budget forward
a couple of years so that's the only
reason i don't support it i'm totally
for us facilitating housing initiatives
in our district but i think it should
come out of taxation
not out of our rates
uh councillor brian and i'm going to
speak um as a member of the we can pay
you council broadcast thank you
to our to a degree i agree with
councillor barnett's comments however
having said that um we have
long been investors and
and it's not so much pension at the
housing because there are people in our
housing at the moment that are not
pensioners but certainly we have been
social providers and to a very high
standard and that account is pretty much
paying for itself the reason why i'm
going to fully support this
is
the sale of the houses which i was
against but having said that i respect
the decision and i want to see that two
and a half million dollars well spent
if uh our staff identify a
lack of resource or ability to well
spend that two and a half million plus
you know hopefully there'll be others
that come on board as well if they need
the resource to
well spend that money i'm going to fully
uh support this recommendation
thank you and all all speakers have
spoke well in this space um this is some
really good points have been made but
can i firstly acknowledge
uh councillor atkinson for his
leadership it has been a probably one of
the more interesting um i think one of
the most interesting committees i've
said on for a long time
and i think he's led up really well um
supported ably by um simon
and the other staff that have been there
because it's this this is a an area
where we could have been so broad in
what we were doing and in fact you have
to go out and have a good look to
understand what the need is and we are
going to need to land at some stage on
effectively making a choice in the space
i i did we did go out and at the
invitation of every field and did he
accounts records and myself and um
rob
and have a look actually and you can't
help but be impressed with the model
that they've developed there but it's
one that we need to make sure that we've
properly researched
in the partnership and what that means
but there's others like the peterborough
model and these other models in the
private sector as well
and they're well documented um
those particular models and tess has run
a couple of uh
of forums where it's been interesting to
talk with other providers
and to see where the private sector's at
and their support of this
but what it needed doing is
tightening this up back to our terms of
reference and that's what it does here
um
uh and clearly articulates the direction
of where we wish to travel in this space
it's fair to say we've all been
ambitious we want to see a result we
could spend that two and a half million
dollars multiple times actually uh it
wouldn't be difficult to do so
and we have land where we can partner
and that's the critical aspect of any
that's needed we do need some work done
on this because if we don't uh
that's why i support bringing the budget
forward because we asked our staff at
the last meeting they were under a lot
of pressure in this space
that you know what what's going to need
to make this this work it's not just
this it's the acquisition
and disposals group as well that needs
some support now rob and his team are
under a lot of pressure so bringing this
forward actually is something that i'm
fully supportive of doing so we achieve
and realize the aspirations we're
setting i don't think there would be
many in our community that disagreed
with that they may well be but that's
i
i fully support that direction because
it needs that work done
the other thing that's changed around
the question around the greater
christchurch partnership
is actually the urban growth partnership
which we now have
uh have agreed or are working on the
final stages with the government and
that's a real game changer
we're going to have two ministers
sitting at the table ministers would
in mahuta and who knows where that heads
but hopefully means further investment
in our communities we've already seen
kayang aura come to us that very kind of
partner
let's see where that takes us there's a
lot going on
in this area and we need to be in a
position as a district
uh to take on those opportunities when
they come along and they're here waiting
for us uh to make the right noises to
them let's see where that goes
the other thing is if we're talking
about the future it's actually
in this space the future for local
government and the work that's around
that this is actually in the area that
we may well end up
having a lot more influence and
depending on where that goes
it's our decision ultimately in our
communities ultimately how much we wish
to be involved or not
uh as the case may be and that's around
the four well-beings and the other
matters that we
have that opportunity and scope to add
if we wish we do have um a good record
with social housing in this district but
we could do so much more if we really
are wherever desire to do so and what
this working group is doing is putting
in place a structure that then will
report back to council with those
options and it will be up to council to
make that final decision so
again i just like to acknowledge um
councillor atkinson all the members of
the working group who are contributing
and doing a really good job in the space
supported ably by our staff it's got my
full support
you're the speakers
people leave consider do you wish to
exercise the wrong reply
thank you mr mayor look i i um
there's a bit of a chicken and egg here
the reason we need to fund this position
is so we can get to an end
and we may end up
exactly where councillor barnett has
talked about that it becomes uh a
government issue
we've been in and councillor brian's
absolutely right
we have invested
in pensioner housing for
many many years
if you talk to anyone on the street of
which if you remember rightly a couple
of years ago i talked about the fact
that i actually
did a survey
non-scientific survey of 85 people
whether councils should be in the
business of pensioner houses i never got
one that said no
85 people told me yes
now
that's anecdotal but that survey may may
end up coming
to fruition somewhere along the line in
a manner that we need to take it um
take it and get it done properly but the
reality is we are in that space we are
there and we need to manage it
efficiently
and we are doing that and we are
upgrading what we have which we haven't
done for many years
so
we are doing those things to do that we
need resource to make that happen now
rob's doing the best he can with the
with the staff that he has he's well
under-resourced at the prison type um
there's two three staff gone from from
his area now we need to make sure that
if we're going to get to the end of this
and have some sensible things coming out
the other end particularly on a two
million two and a half million dollar um
budget that we have there to do
something with um that is that a demo is
the right thing to do
and uh this will deter this group will
determine um the directions that will
hopefully be set and and uh supported by
council in the future so i actually urge
you to support
the uh financial contribution if you
like by way of resourcing to make sure
that this working party and our council
can move forward in this space otherwise
we will just sit there and have this
same conversation in 12 months time
uh thank you uh council atkinson so i'll
now put uh a through to
uh l
and i'll take you separately
all those in favor please say or please
raise your hand
those against
so that's
carriage
we now come to him
i'll put in all those in favor please
raise your
hand okay
those against
i declare that carried
so um
okay do you wish your vote recorded
counselor
thank you so um
you recorded your vote recorded against
chris yep all right
thank you so uh thank you simon
uh and rob
we now come to um item 8.3 which is the
submission on the resource management
uh national environmental standards
that's pages 254-253
don't call in your leading house in this
year
thank you
yep haley just joined us so um yeah
thanks for uh
considering this report the purpose is
to gain council's approval of the
submission
to the ministry for the environment on
the national environmental standard for
sources of human drinking water which is
um being consulted on at the moment
um this an update to this standard was
recommended um
as an outcome of the havelock north
inquiry
um
report and recommendations so it's been
it's been coming for a long time and
it's part of the overall suite of
changes to drinking water
regulation
um and considering the consultation
material we worked closely with um
colleagues at simon district council um
because we as councillors we've got
similar interests and um it was a good
way to share um share thoughts on this
and we also worked with
a technical expert to help
help guide our submission as well
it is
fair to say that the the consultation
document and the submission is is pretty
technical in nature so um
and it's pretty comprehensive too they
asked 41 questions of us
so i've attached the full submission
which is the the 41 questions that we've
been asked in our responses to them
and i definitely won't go through all 41
but i thought um
i could highlight a few key points and
then take questions on any others so
one of the points we noted is that we
were we're being asked to
submit on what protections should should
they be in this zone and this zone in
this zone in terms of catchments for
drinkwater sources
but it felt like there's a little bit of
a lack of clarity for what each
different zone was trying to achieve so
that was one of the key points we felt
that if we're going to
need to um
we give effect to this standard in terms
of the protection to our drinking water
sources we need to understand clearly
what each of these areas is trying to
achieve
and that's also in the interest of
national consistency and efficiency as
well
um a second point we made is that
there is a bit of an issue of timing and
sequencing with this work
when considering this alongside other
things like the water services act
so this piece of legislation would
require regional councils ultimately to
be the ones that determine
what the sources of human drinking water
are
and then inform
water suppliers
but this is still being consulted on and
in the meantime we've got the water
services act telling drink water
suppliers to prepare source water risk
management plans
and input that to water safety plans by
november this year so we're already
doing work in this space
even though this legislation is going to
ultimately tell the regional councils to
do
some of this work so
our key point where we've made
because
the the ministry of food environment
can't change that because the water
services act has already been passed so
the only point we're trying to make is
that
it needs to be acknowledged this will be
an iterative process we'll do what work
we can this year and that'll inform this
year's water safety plans
but then there will be
because it's quite a scientific process
and involves modeling there will no
doubt be further iterations of these um
source water risk management areas in
the future as science gets better or as
we get more input from regional councils
as well um and the third key point that
i wanted to highlight was um
we're pointing out there needs to be
to go alongside a standard that says
this is how you determine what the
catchment the source is and this is the
risks that there might be there needs to
be some way to give legal effect to that
so that you can actually change the land
use
um or activities taking place rather
than just identify that there's a
hazardous activity happening so it's not
explicitly covered what will happen next
other than identify the catchment
identify the hazards but then
there needs to be some more guidance on
what happens once you've done that you
identify there is this activity that
might impact on the source there needs
to be some way to give
protection to that source and it's not
clear how that would be
um my submission point on that isn't it
would need to be done by regional
councils through
a plan change process um
but um in terms of the submission my
point is just they need to they need to
give thought to that otherwise it's not
a
worthwhile document on its own
so i'm happy to take any questions on
that
uh thanks uh colin any questions
[Music]
counselor brian you've still got your
hand up so you might just want to take
it down and you've got to move it unless
you have a question of course
no questions we've got a
series of recommendations sorry haley
did you want to add anything to colin's
report
are you sad um
no no i think he's done a pretty good
summary thanks
he's done an excellent job thank you i
agree
okay someone prepared to move the
recommendation
uh councillor redmond uh seconded by uh
councillor atkinson do you wish to speak
councillor redmond
uh just briefly to say it's a very
comprehensive report colin a lot of it's
over my head
and um
i'm grateful we have people who
understand this so
it is a good submission and i'm happy to
support it thank you cow's recklessly do
you wish to speak
any further speakers
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please say hi
or raise your head sorry
so force a habit really uh contrary put
your hand up
are you all four kids counsel obama are
you against
you're four
yes
thank you all right i declare that kerry
thank you
so next is item
8.4
so that's an update of resource
management and association
and association delegations i would say
um sees association allegations um uh so
that's a report on the name of tracy and
matt are they here mismatched
matthew speaking for tracy or is tracy
joined to join us
i met you're still on mute
there we go found the button finally um
i believe that i will be speaking for
tracy for this one so happy to do so
um just by way of
very quick and
excellent just by the way a very quick
introduction um this is a light review
of of uh delegations um
and i suppose the one thing that i'd i'd
like to point out as well there's quite
a number of changes to the delegation
structure it's actually just following a
current customer practice and just
tidying up some of the delegate the
specific delegations
um does introduce a number of new
delegations to a number of staff but um
it doesn't really change how we would do
things in in practice uh so with that
being said happy to take any questions
uh thanks matt uh any questions
counselor redmond
thank you
thank you matt on
paragraph 3.5
where you've listed the main changes
bullet point
for
um a new delegation to the district
planning and
regulation committee um what exactly is
the agreement there that you're
referring to
oh
excellent so there is no current
agreement um for a mana focus
agreement
but that is in the event the council do
decide to um or get requested to and do
decide to approve
an agreement it just allows for that to
be formally signed off but we currently
don't have any requests for for such an
agreement
oh could you actually explain to me what
that agreement is
sure it's um
the
um
process was introduced in 2017
and it allows for um
council and an irrelevant ewe authority
to enter into an agreement and and the
terms of that agreement can be quite
wide-ranging
um
if i was to equate it it could be for
example very similar to a memorandum of
of understanding that we have with with
the
at the moment
uh to give an example uh the west coast
regional council have a
have an agreement uh with with ewe
authorities over there which looks at um
how they will deal with consenting
arrangements um so the practicalities of
um
of consultation and and what have you so
it could be a very wide ranging matters
that are covered by the agreement
thank you
thank you for the questions counts and
the meetings
i met that's quite the table you've got
there
so on page 361 you've got under section
110 the power to refund financial
contributions to consent holders where
consent has lapsed and we've got the pdu
manager included in that now
so is that that is not currently a
delegation that they have is that
correct
because i know that
we're dealing with at the moment
yeah so that would technically come
through um just the normal rma
delegations because the financial
contribution is um
is actually imposed under the resource
management act but yes that is a new
delegation to the um to that manager who
would be probably the one that's uh you
know working through the negotiations
with that anyway
i'm wondering if we actually
pending how things go with this
particular report when it gets put to
the vote that that might actually
resolve some other issues that we have
in this meeting further on
but also further to that on page
362 on regarding section 176a2
um
where we have delegations to waive the
requirement for an outline plan i
presume that that refers to early in the
process and not waivers to be issued on
agreed odps after they're already
operative
yeah so normally
so the act does provide for wiebers to
outline plans where they're operative
and to give you a practical example of
what might happen there if a school was
looking to
replace a playground that was shown on a
um
on an outline plan with it with it with
another playground so they're upgrading
their playground technically that would
require a change to the outline plan but
of course um
it's something that we would normally do
as a waiver to that plan um
so it's just a really minor minor works
that um you know there's no real point
in doing a a full outline plan approval
process for
so say in the case of say odp 160
if people are seeking
um right a change to that like is this a
delegation which would allow
that to be altered
uh yes so that's that's different so
that's an outline
like an outline plan map within our
district uh plan this is an outline plan
approval
for a designation so yeah well you've
got a designated site you have a you
have an outline plan to it's a little
bit confusing okay no no that's great i
just wanted to just
clarify that and make sure that that was
the case thanks matt sure
no problem
any further questions
um matt just before i um call for a move
issue we should just record for me um
congratulations on your um promotion
something very well deserved don't want
to see you actually go from your current
role because
um congratulations on your new role and
we look forward to working with you in
that new capacity so well done
thank you
um
could i
so we've got a serious recommendation
here some are prepared to move
move the council meetings by
council redmond do you wish to speak
council meetings
only to say that you know this is quite
a comprehensive suite of um common sense
recommendations and
um i've gone through them myself with a
fine toothed comb as you probably picked
up and i
i think that they actually are quite
sensible and
and and for the most part really just
formalize things that that we've already
been doing anyway but make it easier and
more
streamlined i suppose so yes
well done and
i hope that you will support the
recommendation
uh council redmond
uh nothing further to add
mr mayor
and uh i
i support this i think there's a there's
a whole other tiny absence of
formalization of formalizing delegations
that makes perfect sense so
um community uh tracy uh and team for
bringing this forward because it's
always helpful to know that there is a
delegation in place that's that's
correct so um this has been a really
good piece of work and obviously a lot
of work to put it together so commend
the staff for that
a few the speakers
um
do you wish
so uh do you wish to speak uh sorry
is right for applying counselor meetings
no no
okay i'll put the recommendations
all those in favor please raise your
hand
contrary
i do clear that kerry thank you
thanks does eight point thanks man next
is 8.5
which uh there's
a report in the name of rob which is
rural land lease and license policy rob
uh eva
his name is
hawthorne sir
i actually have a um question i'd like
to ask at the front end of this which i
raised with rob earlier
so which may negate us discussing this
today
uh maybe we just come back to a point
rob you're here
sorry can you uh if you do you want your
camera on or not
yeah i'm just about to put it on sorry i
didn't really i thought you were still
on the previous meeting i'll just put it
on there my apologies
just hit another call at the same time
rob can i just ask you a question at the
front end because
it may
maybe we may not consider that today as
a consequence of that i raised with you
earlier
than the
property group report page 391
it says uh e in consultation that
indicates that the policy well the
property group indicated we should
consult on this with our
with knight to
i note in the report
it says that it didn't feel we needed to
so i just wanted to deal with that up
front because if we haven't
appropriately dealt with
that then i i think we should lay this
on the table so we have had that
feedback before we consider this report
and welcome your just initially your
answer to that before and ask you to
speak to the report
um so we
in relation to the
the question of whether we have or not
we haven't specifically
liaised with them on
on the report
in the policy
so and i'm
very comfortable to do so
i am not entirely sure um i i did try
and find the reference that you um you
you i didn't have the specific reference
and i had difficulty spotting it just um
earlier on this afternoon i've had a
couple of other things land on the plate
um but
i don't believe there is any legislative
obligations on us in relation to
the consultation but it is certainly
a sensible and reasonable thing to do
and i'm more than comfortable if in fact
it's the decision of council to
um to look at moving this to putting it
on the table for the next meeting
to
have that liaison
with them
is that
if if we did lay it on the table to make
sure that we have
followed things properly it's page 391
um of the property break report would
that hold
anything up it's already a little
delayed from where it was originally
yeah so certainly um the implications
are most most of these leases are
two or three hundred dollars
and sometimes less
and so they are not significant
spend in their own right so i think if
that um uh there's no criticality from
that point of view
well then i i think i'm just i'm gonna
move that we lay this on the table which
pending
uh
uh a consultation with our with knight
i'm going to put that all those in favor
please say aye
raise your hand sorry
uh contrary
the clear that carried so that will just
lay on the table pending uh that
consultation thank you okay
thanks rob
um
i have no
items measures referred from committees
or community boards
we're now at item
10.1 which is the chief executive's
report on health safety and wellbeing i
asked chief executive wishes to speak to
his report
i'll take the as written and happy to
take questions
thank you any questions for the chief
executive
there appears to be none uh there's a
recommendation contained in the report
some appeared to me of you leaving or
asking questions
i had a question mr mayor thank you
i'm getting used to technology
we're all we're all reacquainting
ourselves
thank you
jim just on page 437
paragraph 4.2.7
you talk about covert
i wondered has there been any
thought
or decision on when vaccine passport
mandates may be reconsidered
given that covet is now endemic in the
community
good question um
we have
just recently decided to
mandate vaccination
access to our all of our campuses
there was a conversation yesterday with
chief executives around the canterbury
region about when we might look at
lifting
but if you actually look at the
progression of the disease
then
the next six to eight weeks it's going
to peak
and we haven't got there yet the numbers
are
increasing every day um on the 25th of
july for example it was about 103 or six
cases in my mercury district two days
later i think it was about 170 or
something so
um now and as the prime minister said
now's not the time to list lift defenses
because the mixture of vaccine passes
as well as all the personal things that
we can do masks washing hands and so on
together means that we will reduce the
transmission of this virus
the other point to notice that in a
world context we have the largest number
of
people per
exposure so it's about an r1 3.7 so for
every person who has omnicronic comes in
contact with someone
about 3.7 to be infected the next next
highest country is
myanmar then we've got china indonesia
and another one so
the point about that is without
vaccination without those personal
measures that i've talked about for the
next two months we're all quite
significantly at risk because of the
high vaccination rate that we have at
the moment it's giving us a good
opportunity for that peak once it
arrives to come down quite quickly
so
as an executive team we're going to
monitor this weekly
but when you put all of that together
for the for at least the next six weeks
it doesn't make any sense to lift
vaccination past requirements
uh thank you i have a second question on
a different topic
on
page 441 and diligent appendix a
the last item on the page refers to a
near miss
with a staff member slipping outside the
kyaboy library
um
that has been the topic of social media
in kyoto where and other people
have indicated that they feel that area
is quite slippery
um are any steps being taken to address
the tile surface to make it less
slippery
i need to come back to you on that
counsellor
thank you it's just been a matter of
concern and i wondered what would happen
if a member of the public
sandra you've just shared your screen do
you think you could unshare yourself
please
i thought i'd disappeared i just
wondered what the reporting process
would be jim if a member of the public
fell
in similar circumstances
well they would be
assuming our staff was aware of them
falling then they would be obliged to
lodge that as an incident so it would
end up
in this reporting system
thank you
thank you and just um
further to what jim said around the
decision
was made around the
vaccine passes there will be a
there will be a communication that comes
out to all elected members and the next
day or so just to
confirm that and as i said earlier
the foreseeable future will
convert all our meetings to zoom don't
intend that to be something that
continues
beyond where necessary but just at the
moment we've seen that as the wise
course of action
council valued a question
followed by council duty
um yes mr mayor i've just seen that the
um seaback is actually opening in cold
stream road tomorrow have we been given
any communications to that happening
for testing locally
no it's thursday i'm told i don't think
it's tomorrow um but i haven't had
anything formally no
so when we do this
no i'm only going
to see
okay well that's fine but i'm advised
differently so i have asked cdhb to make
sure that they do
issue some communications and that's not
the source the cdhb that's the source
here
so they need to confirm that but that
came via tessa i think
but i don't want to speculate on that on
a public meeting so
we'll make sure cdhb do communicate to
us and thinking
but i appreciate the community's desire
to have a testing station and we've been
we have been
pushing really hard that happens through
cdhb through our context and we've made
our land uh in buildings if necessary
available so our staff have been working
really proactively
in that space
okay um
further questions
council duty
thank you
i'm just on the same page 441
and just third bullet point down um
about the aquatic lifeguard and the
behaviour of parents and children i'm
just hoping that um
this incident um
it doesn't happen again
so what has been put in place to protect
the staff
well then chief executive answered that
before he's going to look into that and
come back to check that one as well so
he'll come back to
there'll be a response that comes back
to all of us
that
um jim the kyle point community board as
well
thank you okay
any further questions
we have a um
uh
recommendation
uh who would like to move move to
council duty seconded by
councillor redmond do you wish to speak
councillor duty
councillor edmund
any further speakers
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye contrary of
trashing sorry contrary to clear that
carried
so um next committee minutes for
information we've got the minutes of the
audit risk committee of the 15th of
february pages 447-452
it's just a recommendation that they be
received for information
counselor atkinson looks like you're
moving that
uh second encounter award
uh any discussion i'll put that all
those in favor please say aye
contrary to clear then carriage
got a series of community board minutes
12.1 to 12.3 to be received for
information
council
williams is moving secretary councillor
atkinson do you wish to speak
no
no speakers i'll put that all those in
favor please say hi
contrary
sorry raise your ears raise your hands i
declare that carried
next is
my diary which is pages four seven five
two four seven eight
uh just um this recommendation is there
any questions
someone prepared to move
to council award
secretary councillor concerning which do
you wish to speak
so no further speakers with that i'll
put the recommendation all those in
favor
aye average rave your hand
contrary to clear that carriage
so we now come to
our council
portfolio updates the first is eerie
relationships and last members we could
keep to and the three-minute guide would
be helpful
and jim will give us an indication on
that just on every relationships
um let's
say there's a bit going on in the space
with regards to three waters as you'll
be aware
naitahu certainly have a um
a view around the entity-based model
versus the model of communities for
local democracy are presenting so
in
my role um with our local elite is a lot
of discussion going on
in that space but uh i had nothing
really further to
update apart from we had a meeting
recently with um
tomati uh
tamari and gabe are here at the council
with other partners and it was an
encouraging conversation and
there's a lot more work to be done in
that space it's fair to say specifically
in the space of three waters
if you don't answer any questions
okay um
create a christchurch partnership
either nikki or nibble what to speak or
you want me to do that
just to say that there's
again a lot of work going on
with that urban growth partnership
there's transport relations
conversations which i updated
uh at unr last week around uh connected
approach with a meeting with the
minister on the 30th of
march
but the the partnership's in good shape
there's a lot of work going on there
particularly with the work streams
gc2050 and those other measures that
we've been doing working on for some
time and they're all starting to come
together but we're at the real crunch
point it's really good to see
um
catherine snook back
after maternity leave and it's really
good to see the rigor that she brings
back in that space and alfred and others
are doing a really good job and have
done a very good job in that space and
continue to do so but
um
to get the aspirations around the
spatial planning we've done is
requiring quite a lot of work and we've
got
a lot of our staff working in that space
too and we had a briefing on that at
dpnr the other days you're aware of
where that's well where the likely areas
are and that will be
there'll be further conversation on that
in due course and at partnership people
maybe to answer any questions
thank you um catering water management
strategy council steward
uh thank you
um nothing much to
report in on the strategy there hasn't
been a meeting since we last met as a
council
because the zone committee is meeting um
every second month but there's two
issues i'd just like to
bring up and that is just for your
information
um we have um i'm dealing with um
residents that are on the um on private
wells um on the wood end rangiora road
whose water supply um is now uh
exceeding the um drinking water
standards for arsenic iron and manganese
and they want to join this half a dozen
of them um and they want to join into
the council
uh public supply which um is a obviously
sensible solution and i would like to
see as i said to kelly um
when in fact
costings are firmed up about what this
is going to cost that
the the consultation goes further than
just this half dozen because along that
way there's lots of
properties on private wells
punctuated along that road
the groundwater in that
area is not going to improve in fact
it's getting worse and now it doesn't
comply with drinking water standards
so that's just a heads up the other
issue i wanted to
talk about
on the watery space
is that
i'm dealing with a resident in
septon who has been
flooded out seven times in three years
and evacuated in the last
rain last month
um
the person was fully advised that um
relocated house put into essentially
what is a
a flood prone area um next to a wetland
given all the information from the
council staff but decided to go ahead
she's been there three years and flooded
seven times and i'm talking
one metre high through the property just
under the floorboards of the house
so the question being
when does the council say no
to
relocating or building a house on a
flood pro on a hazard prone site
because um the landowner probably owner
in christian here um was at the meeting
um
ecan last night on flooding and sefton
on the um
uh sefton ashley rating district and now
it's talking about wanting the council
to buy here buy her out so that she can
move on
so just putting it out there
when do we say no
measure that um should be dealt offline
uh i know our staff oh yes
it's really i understand what you're
saying but
it's really up just just a little
outside of the portfolio update here and
so can we we'll have that discussion and
another forum not not here right
certainly
okay
um your time was up anyway but um is
there anything else you wanted to update
no thank you thank you right um
international relationship stupid
americans
um
is that working yes it is
right
um
we've uh just let you know that we've
postponed our meeting uh for
passchendaele until
next month
um
in the closure of the christchurch rsa
there was four medals uh which had come
from passchendaele and been placed in
the christchurch rsa
the consulate for belgium
has secured back those four medals and
they will be placed in the rangiora rsa
uh very shortly of which
we will
all know about soon and there will be a
ceremony in which
i believe the consulate themselves
coming over coming down to uh
to dedicate the medals um back in a
place
um
that uh that they should be is that uh i
believe there's two two soldiers from
kaiapoi and two from rangiora
that received these medals
so they'll be be put there um
nothing on the
chinese relationship that we have with
wuhan at the moment
that's really stagnant at the present
time
and that's about me
thank you any questions of counsel
atkinson
thank you um
reach again uh regeneration council
becky
thank you i've got very little to report
that you don't already know um but a
vandalism down on norman kirk playing
fields the the hoons can't resist as
soon as the grass gets wet they have to
break through the the perimeter fences
and go and do wheelies on our playing
field but we're kind of used to that um
the
mahangakai working group came to
the community of kaibu community board
recently and outlined their plans for
the mahangakai area um hannah rose and
the other lan and kev in the other
landscapers have got the plan together
and that was well received there's a few
minor adjustments to do with the
boundaries that they've drawn whether
they're mahangakai land or not but
that's being addressed by green space
staff
and otherwise the plan is progressing
nicely and
yeah that's me
thank you any questions of council
mickey
thanks al um
next is climate change and
sustainability council meetings
um yeah so i have been informed that a
number of energy reduction measures have
been put in place in the asha building
and rfc
which has resulted in approximately 50
reduction in kilowatt hours
with those efficiency gains which over a
period of 10 years is likely to be
edging towards about a million dollars
i'm excluding carbon
one of the things that we need to be i
guess aware of is that um
the spot price of carbon in the last
year has nearly quadrupled from 22 to 85
and the impact on this hasn't been you
know has yet to be seen in the ymca very
district because
we don't have to be accountable for it
yet but we soon will be
so that's going to be something that we
really do need to take into
consideration
and
i'll i'll
leave that on detail at the moment but
also i would
point out that we have finally just been
able to
advertise for a few different advisor
positions one of which is the lead
advisor sustainable development position
which has just gone live yesterday and
will be advertised for the next four
weeks
and that is something that as you all
know i'm quite excited about because it
it will just give us a lot more capacity
to
prioritize and begin advancing our
climate change and sustainability work
programs because this area has been
stalled for quite some time and i'm
quite anxious to see it get underway
again because
it's not really something that's going
away and it's something we need to get
moving on again so i'm looking forward
to that
that's it thanks
thank you
any questions of nikki
it's quite an achievement for the
building um actually that you say
might be with uh
the team
to our comm staff about at some point
but it's uh it's quite an achievement so
yeah
okay
uh business promotion in town centers
council ward
thank you
um
it's been
quite busy um
we've
we've just started
um our meetings a small committee with
the banking new zealand divestment so
we're underway with that
and progressing starting to progress and
to gain momentum so that we can activate
that so that's underway
um wrangler promotions um we've uh with
no events
happening everything being cancelled of
course um
there's not a lot happening there at the
moment
uh
wrangler airfield um we i think we're
bringing forward a safety officer to the
airfield with um some safety concerns
and our responsibility
uh as owners of the airfield so we're
underway with that and today we meet
with the consultant from taupo this
morning um paul and i and
um and some
um
people so that's getting underway it's
going to be a big job there um for us to
comply with civil aviation and to make
sure that
the waimakariri district that our
responsibility is at the airfield that
we're compliant
the other thing only other thing is that
with um i could really report is that
with the tender openings that inflation
shortage of product and shortage of
labor and busyness of a lot of our
contractors with our shovel ready
projects
is making
our tender openings
okay but of course a little more
expensive than we would like but that's
that's just what's happening in this
environment right now
so that's from me
okay any questions of council award
thank you well that brings us to the end
of council for portfolio updates we i
have no questions understanding orders
no urgent general business understanding
orders
the next items are to be dealt with and
publicly excluded but before we go into
public excluded i think we'll just uh
we have a 15 minute break yourself a cup
of tea and a stretch um
we're back by
five past
three so
i will catch up again in a minute thank
you everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you